هذا ردنا اين ردعنا لعله السؤال الاهم
يعبر اليوم من سكان الجليل الى غلاف غزه
وهم يشاهدون ضربات الفجر على حقول موز
مفتوحه ومشروع زراعي قرب صور جنوب لبنان
وقبلها غارات على مواقع في غزه عشره يقول
جيش الاحتلال ويحسبها باطنان المتفجرات
هذا كان الرد الاسرائيلي على الرد
الفلسطيني بعد اعتداء الاحتلال على الاقصى
ومصليه وفق مراقبين فان الرضع المخيف
لدوله مدججه بالسلاح يتبدد بين اراده
الصمود واليات جديده للمقاومه فاجات
اسرائيل ووضعتها فعليا في مازق لقد جاء
الرد على هذا الحال لانه ببساطه لا يوجد
رد اخر فبينما كانت الصواريخ الاسرائيليه
تنهمر وقعت هجمات في القدس والاغوار
وتوالت الضربات على مستوطنات محيط غزه
قذائف تدخلهم الملاجئ وتبث الخوف ان لم
تفعل اكثر تشكل التطورات الاخيره في
فلسطين ذروه لمسار عمره شهور اعتمد فيه
الفلسطينيون في الضفه الغربيه والقدس على
هجمات مباغته تستهدف قوات الاحتلال
والمستوطنين قاعدتها اضرب واهرب قد يقتل
المنفذ او يعتقل وقد تنتقم القوات
الاسرائيليه من اهله وجدران منزله لكن
الفكره سرعان ما تولد في راس اخر وليس ثم
جيش كاف لاحتلال كل الرؤوس
[تصفيق]
وعندما تجرات قوات الاحتلال فجر الاربعاء
واعتدت اعلى مصلين مسالمين معتكفين في
المسجد الاقصى خلال شهر رمضان فضربت وسحلت
واعتقلت جابت صورهم العالم كله لكنه عجز
في هيئته الدوليه العامه عن اصدار بيان
شاجب ادرك الفلسطينيون مره اخرى الحقيقه
الثابته بانهم وحدهم يجابهون ويقاومون
المبارك الجديد كان ضربات من الكاتيوشا
والجراد اثارت الجدل في لبنان والصدمه في
اسرائيل حين هزت مستوطنات الجليل الغربي
لترسمه مع دخان الحرائق معادله فتح جبهات
متعدده وهي فكره مرعبه لاسرائيل الغارقه
بازمات سياسيه فبدا واضحا حرص مسؤوليها
على الفصل بين الجنوب والشمال الواقع
بينهما ما يشد الجهات بعضها الى البعض
هناك في القدس والاقصى حيث تسقط الخطوط
وتمحي الجغرافيا ويتكثف التاريخ صراعا بين
اصحاب الارض والمحتلين النابشين في
اعماقها بحثا عن اثر زائف
وبانتظار ما سيكون يظل الاقصى ويبقى جدوه
الصراع وقلبه منه البدء والانتهاء صانعا
للاشتباك وقواعده يكسر بصمود اهله فرض
تقسيمه بين اصحابه والمستوطنين بحيث يخرج
المسلمون عندما يريد اليهود القدوم وذاك
ما يواجهونه بالمهج والاجساد بما توفر من
موقف وحجاره وصواريخ